[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
let me just kick things off by saying
that i didn't particularly want to make
this video
as the answer has been floating around
the internet for years in fact i'm sure
that a lot of you
know it already however it has been
requested a fair bit
since i started the channel and i've
never actually
addressed it so i thought i would
finally put this question to sleep
the long-asked question is was nagini
the snake in the zoo from the
philosopher's stone
now we all remember the scene which
kicks off with harry heading to the zoo
with
dursleys on darley's birthday at first
dudley is having a boring time namely
because he wasn't getting much of a
reaction
from any of the animals harry on the
other hand is having a great
but equally confusing time as this visit
to the zoo
was the first time that he realized he
could speak to snakes
while dudley is wandering around
harassing animals out of boredom
harry is speaking with the snake and
when dudley notices
he's immediately drawn to the animation
coming from the snake cage
absolutely thrilled at the prospect of
witnessing the snake
dudley shoves harry aside subsequently
angering him
and causing him to unknowingly use magic
to remove the glass surrounding the
snake's cage
at this stage chaos ensues as the
removal of the glass allows the snake to
escape
the snake then thanks harry as it
slithers away
harry sat up and gasped the glass front
of the bow constrictor's tank had
vanished
the great snake was in coiling itself
rapidly slithering out onto the floor
people throughout the reptile house
screamed and started running for the
exits
and that's seemingly the last we hear of
snakes at least until the goblet of fire
when nagini is introduced voldemort's
slithery companion
this has left some fans wondering are
these snakes
one in the same was nagini the snake
that attacked his friends and family
the same snake that he set free in the
zoo the shorter answer is no
and this is for a couple of reasons
first of all the snake is a brazilian
bow constrictor this is mentioned a
couple of times
first when harry initially approaches
the snake cage
where do you come from anyway harry
asked the snake jabbed its tail at a
little sign next to the glass
harry peered at it bow constrictor
brazil
was it nice there the boa constricted
jabditz tailed the sign again
and harry read on this specimen was bred
in the zoo
oh i see so you've never been to brazil
right away we know that this snake isn't
nagini mainly because nakini is some
kind of venomous viper
not a boa constrictor we know for a fact
that nagini's bite has venom
as she attacked multiple people
throughout the books films
and boa constrictors simply do not have
any kind of venom
the next issue is that the snake from
the zoo is implied to be male
where nagini is female the snake's voice
in the film
was also clearly meant to be male the
last difference worth mentioning is the
size discrepancy
book 1 describes the snake from the zoo
as large enough
to wrap its body twice around uncle
vernon's car
and crush it into a trash can where
nagini is described to be a more modest
12 feet long hopefully that's enough
info to refute the popular nakini
snake zoo theory if you enjoy the
content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
thanks amigo
you